this weekend Congress passed a bill to
avert a government shutdown for 45 days
with hours to spare Democrats actually
tried to delay the vote at the same time
New York Congressman Jamal Bowman
actually pulled the fire alarm at a
house office building he claims he was
trying to open a door kind of a weird
excuse for a former middle middle school
principal who should probably know a
thing or two about fire alarms take a
look at your screen
do you see that right there fire oh that
is the exact door and fire alarm in
question what part of fire alarm looks
like it would open a door Bowman by the
way to a room he by the way was in he's
facing a resolution that would actually
expel him from the house and breaking
earlier tonight house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy is now facing the threatened
motion to vacate The Chair by introduced
by Florida Congressman Matt Gates here
now with the very latest from Capitol
Hill two Freedom caucus members they've
been working really hard Congressman
Byron Donald's in Florida Congress uh
and Texas Congressman chip Roy uh Byron
is from Florida Welcome both of you uh
all right chip let me let me start with
you this is what I don't understand and
and okay if people want to go really far
back you could say okay maybe maybe we
needed the 12 Appropriations bills done
I think that's a fair criticism from
people like Matt Gates and others
however you guys are going to win or
lose together here you both work very
hard on a first proposal that would have
cut eight percent in federal spending
except for securing our borders our
military and our veterans I thought that
was a good 30-day bridge to get the 12
Appropriations you're now at four
complete uh done and finished why didn't
that pass why did some I mean I'm a I'm
a freedom caucus guy I support the
freedom caucus why didn't some people
support that
well Sean it's good to be on it's good
good to be on with my friend Byron and
if anybody should be pulling a fire
alarm it should be Republicans because
of the massive dumpster fire that we
have at the southern border and the
dumpster fire we have here spending a
whole lot of money we don't have in
racking up debt in this I agree with
Matt Gates uh we cannot continue the
status quo he's 100 right about that and
we've been setting out all year to try
to change the status quo this is not
about personalities this is about doing
our job we have a massive crisis at the
southern border endangering our American
citizens and the migrants who seek to
come here we have a crisis in terms of
our debt and spending I would have
chosen the path that you just described
some of my colleagues didn't want to do
that I thought a 30 percent cut to
non-defense non-veteran spending plus
actually securing the border with these
hard-fought hr2 border security package
that Republicans passed for the first
time in our history we didn't do it
under Trump we didn't do it at any point
in the past we did that and we did that
because of the work we did in January to
get the speaker to put conservatives in
the right place so I think Republicans
need to learn how to take wins and then
get another win with them well that's
what we're going to try to do right now
yeah because your second plan was you
were going to cut the federal
bureaucracy by 30 percent you're gonna
on except for defense that would have
gone up 28 billion except for veterans
benefits that would have gone up 2.5
billion in the same to secure our border
uh and that would have been combined
with hr2 which is your border bill that
would actually uh seriously secure the
border and fiscal responsibility and
border security I think have got to be
Republicans top two priorities that
would have worked why didn't that pass
well you'll have to talk to the ones who
voted against it look the reason it
didn't pass because some people didn't
want to have anything that continued
moving in the Direction with something
like a continuing resolution but here's
my view if you get Cuts in place and if
you get the Republican conference to
Rally around cutting spending and
agreeing with the argument of no
security no funding then we ought to
stick with it and so that's where I
would have gone but here's we sit here
where we are now with a 45-day
continuing resolution that I opposed
that Byron opposed that 90-something
Republicans oppose so now we've got to
work hard we've got to use the leverage
we have in front of us let's be very
clear there's going to be a lot coming
at us over the next 45 days we need to
get the Appropriations bills done under
the debt ceiling uh deal get spending
down and we need to make sure that not
one dollar is going to Ukraine not one
dollar is going to Ukraine unless we do
our job to secure the Border first and
unless we're paid for anything we do
unless we get Appropriations done and
even then I'm not interested in
continuing to fund a proxy or but we've
got to do our job to leverage that to
force change okay Byron if you can get
spending cuts and get the border secure
uh and and not negotiate away and I
agree on the Ukraine issue too uh and do
it through the Appropriations process
can that happen in the next 45 days and
then the Republicans win and then all
pressure goes where it belongs and
that's to Mitch McConnell Senate
uh Sean I think we can do that but the
number one way you get that done is that
House Republicans got to stand together
in that battle border security like chip
is saying that's got to be the number
one issue that we fight for in this in
this spending battle we're gonna have
with the Democrats in the White House
Joe Biden is terrible we know that the
Democrats in the Senate don't work and
they don't do anything we know that but
the border is hurting all Americans
regardless of their party that's where
House Republicans need to stand but the
only way we can cut spending secure this
border go after the weaponized
government at the FBI and the doj the
woe stuff in our military is we gotta
stand together and work hard to get
these things done we can do it in 45
days but we got to be United in that
effort what about the motion to vacate
is that going to be a problem
yeah Sean I'll tell you I think it is
going to be a problem because the first
thing it does it takes away floor time
where you're supposed to be actually
going through amendments on the
appropriation bills that's one number
two yeah it's going to lead to divisions
in the conference how are we going to be
United as a conference if we're divided
on that question well you're either
going to win or lose together
so somehow there's got to be a sweet
spot where you are the party of fiscal
responsibility border security that you
don't give in and and I think that
that's good politics at the end of the
day I hope you guys can work it out we
appreciate your time
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else